welcome to this video I'm playing Zoltan
med VG again here with black tactical ok
let's see what we get here ok this is
funny line can I try 96 normally you
take here maybe you can try this line
for a change is playing Bishop c3m I see
ok I wanted to play g6 but Bishop c3 is
very very annoying answer to that so I
probably need to get things are
developed maybe I still can play g6 if
you place 93 for example very very very
concretely played I cannot take now
obviously
okay I cannot spend any much longer
maths looks good for white it's probably
not a very successful opening experiment
bishop we should be seven does not
really look good hmm how do I actually
develop this it's not not clear
Wow poor had that day that he played
very well the opening here maybe I can
do this getting out of the bishop here
getting away from the bishop and trying
to disturb him okay yeah maybe maybe
this one and then capturing yeah I
cannot take this anybody to accurately
don't think so let's just let's just try
to get out of the blue castles be solid
maybe I can take on d5 to initiate and a
pawn structure change Wow can I think I
think I'm not going to get get blasted
away quickly here or anything it is it
is still fairly solid white is better
but it is to have a playable position
for the moment Quinn system when i get
to end each other it was centralized
stuff
yeah f5 f5 is a move that might be
coming g6 yeah probably need to they
cannot yet sacrifice but maybe nine f3
b 98 98 voix ugly yeah if I take I'm
definitely not in good shape but what
what what should I do here it's simply a
simply a bad position
the ship t6 can go to g5 this is this
position just totally sucks
just a very bad position a totally
unrefuted my opening here I mean refute
I don't know but the position is just a
wreck how do i maybe night a five-night
be a to c 6 but he has many ways now
Knight f6 is good or many things are
good now maybe I can get an ID for as a
as a pawn sacrifice come on getting
opposite colored bishops 95 coming okay
but this is definitely the this is
progress I see Miss plate I think I'm in
the game now again
I'm still alive
ty morning for coming good Africa's 70
the B porn is also a liability for him
so I should have time to play Luke a
seven his king is active but also
slightly insecure
probably wants to play see fire just
prevent it for the moment wanted
together a quick move quick move in
check be seven
I ass got King b5 him
I cannot believe that I'm stead of
losing this nonsense again oh man he had
totally screwed this up and then I
screwed it up again ah come on black
resigns I mean here I'm just I'm just
busted yeah it you should just win this
and then he played this this is just
totally died f2 is this is terrible
after that I'm talk i'm completely ok
again then I again miss played it this
is really really stupid yeah this is
strong of course he gets the beep on I
should never lose this again you never
write it's a matter of precision I rook
c8 is also better I can just stare this
as this is in fact much better yes
absolutely no way forward in this
position there's nothing going on I can
never play before you can just shuffle
here no idea whatever this this is
giving him a little bit of hope with
before still I don't think yeah maybe
maybe the King blocks the d4 pawn I
thought I have enough counter play but
the the idea with c5 and b5 is very
strong now I does much better yet thats
it's true I still need to be precisely I
mean he played it badly but I still need
to be precise rook c8 for example he has
better alright whatever I should just
avoid to trade to trade on d3 I was just
wanted I just wanted to keep it simple
that it's not really doing that it's not
keeping it simple and I mean here he
just I don't I don't know what he's
doing here what what what this move is
you can just take if he wants I mean I
was glad to have opposite color
chips but this this position is just
dreadful for black quite clearly yeah
yeah it's annoying loss okay thanks for
watching